police departments Nationwide regularly
receive a document from the doj entitled
hate crime data collection guidelines
and training manual and the point of the
manual is to educate officers on how to
identify hate crimes and how to report
them to the feds for the all-important
hate crime statistics that you often see
in the media they were especially
everywhere during the Trump presidency
and you still see these hate crime
figures cited today in fact these other
statistics that supposedly prove that
white supremacy is the greatest threat
this country has ever faced now given
all of the Reliance on these numbers
it's strange that no one ever talks
about the doj manual you'd think there'd
be some curiosity about how these
numbers are determined
so I decided to read the document for
myself and one of the one of the most
extensive sections of this manual as it
turns out is the exercises section and
these are the hypothetical scenarios
that the doj provides to police
departments to help them see you know
how hate crimes actually look it helps
them illustrate hate crime law and one
of the exercises is about two gang
members who assault a random Hindu
person with a baseball bat the exercise
states that quote when taken into
custody the two juveniles reported they
committed the assault because they want
the Hindu people to go back where they
came from
as you probably guess the doj's manual
instructs officers to categorize this
incident as a hate crime because of the
offender's derogatory comments about the
Hindu community
seems straightforward enough if you beat
somebody up while yelling go back where
you came from then you're committing a
hate crime and if hate crime means
anything then that would have to qualify
what's interesting is that a real-life
version of this exercise just played out
earlier this month in New York City 51
year old Asian American Sue young was
traveling on a subway train in Greenwich
Village supposedly one of the nice areas
of the city with her husband and her 11
year old twin girls and
that's when a three black teenage girls
started screaming and cursing at Soo
young and she tried to play it off tried
to laugh it off her husband suggested
the girls might be uneducated a rather
plausible Theory I would say and then
the teenagers told Sue young to go back
where she came from within seconds one
of the teenagers a 16 year old girl
began attacking Young
and then for good measure that teenager
beats a random bystander who was
recording the incident now given all of
those facts you think it's safe to call
this incident a hate crime since it
pretty much mirrors exactly the scenario
in the doj's own hate crime manual go
back where you came from is an admission
that the attack relates to the victim's
national origin race or religion
pretty straightforward to any reasonable
person
but apparently it's not straightforward
to New York police because they've
decided not to charge the teenagers in
this case with a hate crime
they found them arrested them uh and and
they know that this a teen girl told her
victim to go back to her country
but there won't be any hate crime
charges
that's not because the evidence is
unclear I mean there's no disputing any
of the facts it's all been established
it's all on video watch
new information on that disturbing video
showing teens berating and then
attacking a family on an F train in
Greenwich Village you saw this video 16
year old girl has been arrested and
charged with two counts of assault the
teen was one in a group of three girls
who screamed in a family of four telling
them to go back to where they came from
the situation quickly became violent
with one of the teens even assaulting
the woman who captured the incident on
her cell phone
go back where you came from followed by
a beating under the doj's guidelines
that's a hate crime I mean it's
literally one of the exact scenarios
they specify as a hate crime
but it won't be recorded as one now if
you're the kind of person who trusts
government statistics on crime or on any
Topic at all then this development is
mind-blowing
I mean very surprising right it's the
kind of thing that might make you ask
some unapproved questions for example
you might wonder
is it really true as multiple Outlets
have reported that the anti-asian hate
crime epidemic is caused by all those
Maga Republicans that secretly live in
New York and San Francisco
are American Republicans not only
controlling the weather and melting the
ice caps but also patrolling the streets
looking for Asians to randomly assault
can we trust that data
and if that's happening then why is that
never caught on video I mean why is
literally every video that we see of a
an Asian person being assaulted in an
apparent hate crime why is it in every
case a black person doing the assault
like why have we never actually seen the
white person doing this
well it might be because um the real
numbers are quite different from what
you hear in the media here are the real
numbers as the City Journal recently
reported quote while black perpetrators
account for 27.5 percent of violent
attacks against Asians Asians commit
less than 0.1 percent of violent attacks
against blacks indicating little role
for proximity
most violent attacks against individuals
of a particular racial group are
committed by other members of that group
except for Asians where a plurality is
committed by blacks in fact blacks are
responsible for
305 percent more violent crime against
Asians than neighborhood demographics
would predict while whites and a Spanish
commit significantly fewer attacks
against Asians than would be expected
so what this suggests is that hate crime
statistics are meaningless I mean
totally bogus
they they misrepresent and vastly
under-report the amount of anti-asian
racial violence committed by black
people especially young black people
what happened in Sue Young's case is not
as unusual as it might appear to be
clear now there are many other reasons
to conclude that these hate crime
statistics aren't reliable
the overwhelming majority of police
departments report zero hate crimes
every year for example so you heard that
right zero hate crimes
in 2019 fewer than 15 percent of the
nearly 16 000 jurisdictions reported a
single hate crime to the doj even though
they participate in the doj's reporting
system but they didn't report any
so this is a this is a tiny sample size
we're talking about here and these
police departments the few that are
reporting hate crabs they're not
verifying as a legal matter that any
hate crime occurred
the handcom statistics they don't refer
to hate crimes that have been proven
they don't refer to convictions they
refer to reports of hate crimes as the
doj manual says so all it takes is a cop
to code a case as hateful
and boom you have a hate crime no jury
or judge is required as central banks in
countries like China India and Australia
begin transitioning to a digital
currency the Federal Reserve has been
contemplating the same for the U.S with
a digital currency the government could
track every single purchase you make
officials could even prohibit you from
purchasing certain products or easily
freeze or seize part or all of your
money these are some of the reasons
concerned Americans reached out to Birch
gold they want to have a physical asset
like gold that's independent of the US
dollar you can protect your IRA or 401K
by diversifying with gold from Birch
gold today historically gold has been a
safe haven at times of high uncertainty
which is right now unfortunately learn
if gold is right for you to text Walsh
to 989898 and they'll send you a free
info kit on gold with an A plus rating
with a Better Business Bureau thousands
of happy customers and countless
five-star reviews I trust Birch gold to
help you diversify into gold if a
central bank digital currency becomes a
reality it'll be nice to have some gold
to depend on again text Walsh 298-9898
these are the gaping holes in the hate
crime reporting system that you never
hear about so you have to ask
why do we have this hate crime system if
it's not producing anything remotely
resembling accurate results and for that
matter even if we could measure this
accurately
why does anyone bother recording hate
crimes I mean why not record crimes that
are motivated by say greed or lust
why does the hate crime designation
persist as I've often argued the most
dangerous people in society are those
motivated not by hate but by
indifference to human life by callous
disregard
so why don't we have a separate Federal
category for in different crimes
why give hate crimes this special place
of honor
especially when they aren't being
recorded in any kind of honest or
consistent way
well Sue young and her husband offer us
some Clues on that front they've uh
they've come out and given interviews
absolving their attacker of personal
responsibility it's pretty amazing watch
I did Sandra frightening it was her
husband as well they've moved on left
our city uh continuing their vacation
but hoping to soon return still shaken
by all they've been through but offering
a message this afternoon of
understanding and forgiveness
I keep running through oh I should have
done this I should have done this I you
know XYZ it happened so fast battered
and bruised from her New York Subway
encounter Sue young and her husband
still shocked by how quickly taunts on
the F train spun wildly out of control
you just go into survival mode and you
just want to protect you know yourself
you could have uh attacked them you did
not you defended yourself I I could have
gotten up and attacked them I didn't
that's them on the left riding the train
with their 11 year old twin girls
Thursday night they say the three teens
sitting across from them started
laughing and pointing and when they
didn't back down quickly became more
aggressive than violent the woman who
filmed the confrontation says one of the
girls also assaulted her three times
start over took me by the hair threw me
on the ground and started punching me
the teens on video telling the family to
go back where they came from Top
officials at the MTA and the state
weighing in today I haven't seen the
video but I'll tell you this there's no
place for hate on our system it's being
investigated this woman had
no reason to be attacked whatsoever
there is no tolerance for this in the
state of New York but from the victims
themselves who've been talking to
investigators there's compassion we
don't know what battles other people
have in their lives but I can imagine
they are probably not as privileged and
that has probably a lot of a lot to do
with their outlook on the world and and
and the anger they may have right
so was this a hate crime ask the victims
they'll tell you absolutely not doesn't
reach the high bar that needs to be sent
for that they say was it a crime
absolutely and they're talking to
investigators here the sixth Precinct
who are still looking to talk to those
three teenage girls
we don't know what battles other people
have in their lives but I can imagine
they're probably not as privileged Sue
Young's husband says he's apparently
justifying why he allowed his wife to be
accosted right in front of him it didn't
do anything about it he adds quote that
probably has a lot to do with their
outlook on the world the anger they may
have
oh those poor kids
so therefore the couple agrees what
happened to them was not a hate crime
they're happy they took their beating
instead of fighting back
now what that couple is saying out loud
without realizing it is the real reason
hate crimes persist as a category the
point of hate crimes isn't really to
measure hate
the point is to measure victimhood where
the victims happen to be the primary
voting blocks of the democratic party if
you have privilege meaning if you're
Asian or white then hate crimes can't
happen to you if you're attacked because
of your ethnicity uh and you're in one
of those two groups then you should
rationalize it you should justify the
actions of your attackers
one of the many problems with this
reasoning other than the fact that lack
of privilege cannot conceivably justify
beating up a woman in front of her kids
is that plenty of poor people don't
commit violent crimes I mean we can
measure this the assumption that Sue
young and her husband have that their
attacker must have had a really hard
life
is not an explanation much less an
excuse for what happened the Twitter
account monitoring bias has looked into
the numbers on this and the account
found that quote in NYC where the
percentage of Asians who live in poverty
is close to that of blacks the Black
arrest rate for murder was 13 times
higher than for Asians in 2020.
so in other words black people aren't
simply committing acts of violence
because many of them are poor it's not
that simple you know the black violent
crime rate is still disproportionately
high even when you control for income
level and economic class and that sort
of thing
so the point is that these Punks on the
subway they're not really angry or going
through any great personal struggle and
if they are who cares
like you lose the right to be to be
pitied when you start victimizing other
people
that's not even what's happening here I
mean they're they're bored and spoiled
and they've been empowered to act
however they want with the knowledge of
their behavior will always be excused no
matter how heinous it is
they have no fear of punishment
and that way they're like the rich
antifa kids who spit on cops or the
lawyers who threw firebombs at a police
cruiser during the BLM riots they're
like the Thugs who you see going into
Nordstrom or the Apple Store walking out
with all the merchandise they know
they're not going to suffer immediate
severe and long-lasting Punishment they
might not suffer any punishment at all
they know their victims are weak and
often lack the will to defend themselves
so they take advantage of it
that's the reality
and some people won't acknowledge it
this reality even when it hits them in
the face many times over on the subway
in front of their kids
they've been fed so many lies including
from the doj's hate crimes reporting
system that they're incapable of
diagnosing the problem much less trying
to solve it
and what will happen is that their
weakness will perpetuate violence on all
sides because people can only take so
many random Subway beatings and
stabbings before they start defending
themselves
you know you heard there in the clip the
youngs were proud of themselves for not
quote attacking the black teens who were
harassing them but um people are growing
weary of that kind of passivity
of this submissiveness in the face of
Lawless violent thugs
the dam can't hold forever
and there will be a lot more uh Daniel
penny is coming soon
and when that happens
the doj will call it hateful they'll
call it a sign of rampant white
supremacy
what they'll never admit what they know
is true
is that it will be their fault
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed